when was the first time that you heard
Kimmel say sorry Matt Damon we ran out
of time apologies to Matt Damon ran out
of time he literally pulled my name out
of thin air one night and the way he
told me the story he said he had like he
said I had a ventriloquist and a guy in
a gorilla suit as my guests and I just
said kind of as a throwaway my apologies
to Matt Damon we ran out of time so sure
but he could have said Brad Pitt he
could have said you know George he could
have said somebody else but he just for
some reason maybe I had a movie out that
week or something Matt Damon apologies
ran out of time I want to apologize to
Matt Damon
[Applause]
[Music]
damage he changed the course of both of
our Lives we've we've we've kept this uh
Feud going for you know it's got to be
15 years now we've had a lot of fun
doing it I want to apologize to Matt
Damon we ran out of time for him but
we'll definitely try to work him in
sometime in the next 20 years what the
actual what the 20 years